the Joe Rogan experience um I get your
greg Giraldo I give you a great greg
Giraldo story right okay so this to me
sums up a comedian who's also a drug
addict 2006 William Shatner roasts
Comedy Central I'm Geraldo was just
hitting with the roast she was gonna be
a big deal but I party with him a couple
of times and you know we both had the
same problem so uh so we were the only
two guys coming from New York City to do
the Shatner roast
this was o-64 Comedy Central so I'm at
the JFK first lounge
first first-class lounge waiting for my
plane and I know Greg is supposed to be
on a plane he shows up five minutes
before the plane takes off and he goes
our team and he like hugs me sweating he
goes I'm tweaking like he was on taking
amphetamines so I go he goes I'm not
getting on a plane I go dude you're hot
you're like the best guy at these roasts
now you have to get on a plane does your
career and he goes I can't get on a
plane I go you have to get on a [ __ ]
plane so I had all this vicodin I
smuggled under my under my sock I said
take a couple of vicodin and have a beer
so I got him a beer and he started to
calm down a little bit I literally held
his hand okay I held his hand got him on
a plane I changed my seat to sit next to
him he was too paranoid to go to the
[ __ ] bathroom so I regard the
bathroom so no one could come in and I I
we get to LA now we got to go to a dress
rehearsal at CBS Radford
Farrah Fawcett was on that roast so now
he's still freaking out paranoid and he
he want he goes I'm gonna hug Farrah
Fawcett I go you can't go near Farrah
Fawcett
he goes how about a hug fire I have to
kiss her I got cheese on us I go get
arrested your careers gonna be over
you're gonna be arrested for sexually
assaulting Farrah Fawcett on
amphetamines so I go you just gotta calm
the [ __ ] down
we get through the dress rehearsal and
he goes please don't tell anybody and
now I've been there so I know what he
says so I go I want so we go back to the
hotel I leave my room I sit by him like
Florence [ __ ] Nightingale I've given
him like hot compresses and [ __ ] the
morning the next morning the cars coming
to get us to take us to the show at noon
and he comes out of it
he comes down to breath because I
I think I'm I came down he hugs me he's
crying he goes thank you so much I go
dude you would have done the same thing
for me okay so now we go to the roast
he's the first thing he says he goes
look at you already you fat [ __ ] I
just I practically made out with him I
stopped him from sexually assaulting one
of the Charlie's Angels he won yeah if
he won
powerful he goes I've never said that to
another you would be or since very few
people hardly ever have oh my god oh my
god again this is something he is things
you wish you had on tape about 1998 ish
me Mitch Hedberg and greg Giraldo both
did sets we all three listed sets at the
Comedy Cellar
and there was an old diner on 9th and
23rd called Chelsea Square diner I don't
know if it still anymore the three of us
was me Greg and Mitch and if you if you
ask why God spared me out of that three
I have no idea it's just sheer luck but
God spared me for some reason I don't
know why and I remember talking the
three of us were talking about about
drugs and Hedberg he told this to a
couple people and I didn't know Mitch's
well I did a couple of gigs with him but
you know he said you know a lot of
people are trying to get me to stop I'm
never gonna stop he said I'm just just
don't waste your time I'm never gonna
stop doing it I love it that much and
you know
at the time I didn't realize how dark
that was and he died you know he's been
dead almost 15 years now you talk about
a real genius you know and like he just
was like I I just I know I can never
stop like that's how much it takes it
takes over to the point where you know
you know you might die because I don't
care I want to do it this way yeah you
know so again well remember when he
almost died from gangrene yes he was
shooting this the same hole he was going
through he might have been with a towel
I don't know
and Louis black they did a tour together
and again that's one of the saddest
stories yet the security at the airport
smelled the gangrene oh that's how they
found out yeah and they found [ __ ] and I
think he beat the case I think they
found like powerful nail your stuff but
you're talking about you know one of the
best maybe the best joke writer ever and
he just doesn't he just like I just why
again when you live in this life like
stand-ups most of us dreamed of doing
this our whole lives and now you're
doing it who's gonna tell you to stop
anything I think with him to they were
inseparable they'll stand up in the
heroine together yeah
like Miles Davis said they get what
we're playing the trumpet you knows no
meaning again you're talking about
extreme personalities yeah John Belushi
yeah and again like you say you have the
same personality but it just manifested
itself in different ways
[Applause]